>> THE EDUCATION SYSTEM IN
AMERICA REELING FROM THE MASSIVE
DAMAGE DONE BY LIBERAL COVID
LOCKDOWNS.
KIDS FALLING BEHIND BOTH
ACADEMICALLY AND MENTALLY.
NOW THERE'S NO ONE AROUND TO
TEACH THEM.
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
DEALING WITH A MASSIVE TEACHER
SHORTAGE, AND BIDEN SECRETARY OF
EDUCATION SAYS IT COULD EVEN GET
WORSE.
>> WHERE THE DOORSTEP OF A
CRISIS IN OUR COUNTRY AND IF WE
DON'T TAKE IT SERIOUSLY, WE WILL
HAVE SCHOOLS CLOSING AND WE
DON'T NEED THAT.
>> INSTEAD OF DEALING WITH A
PRESSING PROBLEM, SCHOOL AND
STRANGERS ARE MORE FOCUSED ON
WOKE ACADEMICS.
FOR INSTANCE, RIGHT NOW IN
VIRGINIA EDUCATION PROPOSAL IS
SEEKING TO STRIKE AT
GEORGE WASHINGTON AS "FATHER OF
THE U.S."
BUT DON'T WORRY, TEACHER UNIONS
ARE BLAMING REPUBLICANS FOR THE
STAFFING CRISIS.
TOP UNION BOSS ANDY WEINGARTEN
WHO WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN KEEPING
KIDS IN ISOLATION, IS BLAMING
THE SHORTAGE ON REPUBLICANS WHO
SHE SAYS POLITICIZE PUBLIC
EDUCATION.
OKAY, SO, GREG.
ANDY WEINGARTEN SAYS IT'S ALL
THE REPUBLICANS FAULT THIS
CRISIS THAT WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE
LOVE IS BECAUSE OF REPUBLICANS.
WHAT COULD SHE BE TALKING ABOUT?
>> THERE IT'S RIGHT ABOUT
GEORGE WASHINGTON.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE THAT HE SAYS
HIS NORMATIVE MALE.
WE'VE DONE STORIES WHERE
CHILDREN ARE LITERALLY MISSING
FROM THEIR SCHOOLS NOW LIKE
1 MILLION, 2 MILLION, 3 MILLION,
AND WE HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
TEACHERS.
WHAT DOES IT TELL YOU ABOUT THE
SYSTEM?
THAT THE SYSTEM SUCKS, IT
SOMETHING CALLED THE TEACHERS
UNION THAT'S RESPONSIBLE IN
COMPETITION WITH THE SYSTEM
BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY THAT THE
ROCK CAN BE MAINTAINED WHICH IS
WHY WHAT'S HAPPENING IN ARIZONA
IS SO AMAZING.
GOVERNOR DUCEY, IS THAT HOW YOU
SAY IT?
OUR VERY OWN GOVERNOR DUCEY.
SO THAT ALLOWS CHOICE AND
COMPETITION AND AN EXPERIMENTS,
IF THEY DO WELL OTHER STATES
WILL FOLLOW THROUGH AND YOU WILL
SEE A HUGE CHANGE.
SHUT OUT TO THE COREY KID
BECAUSE HE'S THE GUY BEHIND THE
MOVEMENT.
EVERY PARENT SHOULD FOLLOW UP
WHAT HE'S DOING BECAUSE THE
PARENTS THAT ARE PUSHING THIS,
THIS COULD REALLY CHANGE THINGS
BECAUSE THE PROBLEM WITH AMERICA
IS ROOTED IN EDUCATION SYSTEM.
IF WE TALK ABOUT COLLEGE, NO, BY
THE TIME PEOPLE ARE 18, THEIR
LIVES ARE RUINED BY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
IF WE GOT TO GET THEM BEFORE
THAT.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE FACT THAT THEY
ARE NOT ADMITTING IT'S THERE
DOING?
THE FACT THAT KIDS HAVE BEEN OUT
OF SCHOOL FOR A YEAR AND A HALF,
TWO YEARS BECAUSE THEY SAID THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THE PROPER EQUIPMENT
TO GO IN AND TEACH.
EVEN NOW THEY ARE SAYING KIDS
MASKS.
>> IS A HUGE PROBLEM, THERE'S A
CRISIS UPON THIS LOOK OKAY,
YOU'VE BEEN IN POWER FOR NEARLY
TWO YEARS.
IF ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU THINK
THERE'S A CRISIS?
IT'S LIKE THE BABY FORMULA
THING, THEY KNEW IT ABOUT FOUR
MONTHS AND DIDN'T TELL THE
PRESIDENT.
YOU'VE GOT A SHORTAGE OF WHAT
ELSE?
POLICE, DETECTIVES, CORRECTIVE
OFFICERS, WHY IS THAT?
NOT JUST THE PAY, BECAUSE YOU'RE
GOING TO PUBLIC SERVICE AS A
TEACHER OR POLICE OFFICER,
CORRECTIONS BECAUSE YOU REALLY
WANT THE HIGH PAY, BECAUSE IF
YOU GO INTO THOSE JOBS, IT'S
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO BE A PART OF
SOCIETY, YOU WANT TO BE A PART
OF RAISING CHILDREN AND PART OF
THE EDUCATION SYSTEM.
TEACHERS LOVE TEACHING, BUT WHAT
HAPPENED?
THEY WATCH THESE KIDS THAT
EITHER DON'T COME BACK OR THEY
HAVE SO MUCH LEARNING LOSS THEY
CANNOT POSSIBLY KEEP UP AND
THERE GETTING JUDGED BY THAT.
PARENTS AREN'T BEING
RESPONSIBLE, 96% OF THEM ON THE
AMERICAN TAXPAYERS PAY FOR
SCHOOLS DURING COVID HAS NOT
BEEN SPENT.
THE FINANCIAL INCENTIVES AREN'T
GOING TO DO IT AND THE POLICIES
HAVE TO CHANGE.
IT'S ALSO DRIVING THEM OUT.
>> THE FACT THAT DANA TALKED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT COVID MONEY
IS A BIG EXPENSE AND TEACHERS
ARE SAYING WE ARE NOT BEING PAID
ENOUGH.
IS THERE ANY WAY TO RESOLVE THIS
IN TERMS OF WHERE IS THE COVID
MONEY?
WILL SOMEONE TELL ME WHERE IT IS
AND WHO'S USING IT AND WHO HAS
THE RIGHT TO USE?
>> THE ADMINISTRATION IS COMING
OUT SAYING WE NEED TO PAY
TEACHERS MORE.
IT TEACHERS GAVE $20 MILLION TO
DEMOCRATS AND JOE BIDEN IN THE
2020 CAMPAIGN.
LISTEN, I DON'T MIND PAYING GOOD
TEACHERS MORE, BUT TEACHERS MAKE
20% LESS THAN PEOPLE WITH
SIMILAR DEGREES.
BUT THEY ALSO WORK 20% LESS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE SUMMERS OFF.
WE SHOULD PAY GOOD TEACHERS
MORE.
THEY WON'T ALLOW US TO LOOK AT
THE PERFORMANCE OF THE TEACHERS.
OUR KIDS LEARN HOW TO READ,
WRITE, DO MATH, BUT IF YOUR
TEACHER IS WOKE, WE SHOULDN'T
PAY THEM MORE.
IF YOU STOP PROMOTING RACISM,
THOUGH, HEY, I'LL TEACH THERE.
>> THE WHITE TEACHERS GET FIRED
FIRST.
>> BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT IF THERE IS A SHORTAGE OF
TEACHERS, PEOPLE LIKE
RON DeSANTIS IS SAYING YOU CAN
RELEASE THEM WITH X POLICE
OFFICERS.
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO SAY,
THEY'VE GOT TO BE COMPETENT, BUT
IT'S AT THE SAME TIME I'M NOT
SURE I WOULDN'T RATHER HAVE A
COP TEACHING A KID RATHER THAN
SUBLEASING THE COUNTRY IS RACIST
AND THE COLOR OF YOUR SKIN
DECIDES YOU'RE A RACIST.
>> THE POINTS ABOUT BRINGING
PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN IN OTHER
FIELDS BACK TO TEACHING IF THEY
PASS THE EXAMS AND THEY'RE
QUALIFIED TO TEACH, WHATEVER THE
SUBJECT LEVEL IS, I WOULD
WELCOME IT.
YOU WANT THE BEST PEOPLE IN THE
CLASSROOM AVAILABLE FOR THE
KIDS.
MONEY IS A HUGE PIECE OF THAT
AND EVERY BUDDY'S CAMPAIGN ON
PAYING TEACHERS MORE, TAKE MONEY
OUT OF THEIR AMERICAN RESCUE ACT
TO DO THAT.
PART OF WHAT'S GOING ON IN
CITIES LIKE NEW YORK I WAS OUT
WITH A COUPLE LAST NIGHT WHO
MOVED TO CONNECTICUT BECAUSE
THEY ARE CHILD -- THEY LIVED IN
OAKLAND -- SHE WENT INTO THE
LOTTERY SYSTEM AND GOT THE 11 OO
LIVE ACROSS THE STREET FROM THE
SCHOOL DID NOT GET ZONED AND FOR
IT.
WHAT DID THEY DO?
THEY MOVED TO A STATE WHERE
THERE ARE GREAT PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND THEY KNOW THAT THEIR
CHILDREN WILL BE GOING TO THAT
SCHOOL.
PARENTS NEED SECURITY TO KNOW
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE MAKING A
REAL ESTATE INVESTMENT ONE OF
THE TOP REASONS FAMILIES MOVE
FOR THE GRADE SCHOOL THAT YOUR
KID IS GUARANTEED A SPOT IN THE
SCHOOL NO MATTER WHAT GOES ON.
>> HOME SCHOOL.
>> I THINK IT'S A GREAT
APPROACH, YOU KNOW IF I INTEND
LIKE-MINDED FAMILIES, P/E
TEACHER AT $200,000, HAVE A
HOMESCHOOL POD.
>> THERE'S A LOT THEY CAN DO.
BUT I WANT TO KNOW WHERE IS THE
MONEY.
UP NEX